hallo mein name ist bürger herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ist mal
wieder bei twitter gesagt dass ich mir
irgendwelche videoleinwänden wollen
erstmal die daten der bevor glaube ich
im monat gemacht also wenn ihr wollt
sich dass wir nicht öfters machen dann
lacht man nämlich in das sie wollen
wissen willst du mir komplett einwendung
die ich mir ausgesucht habe ist dieses
mädchen die mit mir gassi gehen will
wow das ist eine einladung oft mit hey
wieder man nicht denkt man sich ja erst
addiert sich zu hause aufnehmen tag
ersten fehler wohl was tust du da also
mir wurde wieder zugewendet von einem
user der einen männlichen namen hatte
und ich denke mal dass dafür ein mädchen
ist also kein junger erfüllen wie komm
du an liebe den klub von diesen mädchen
und zweiten warum das mädchen überhaupt
so einen klick auf send ob es mich
anhören wenn du mich frage begast sie
gehen wollen ja klar
ok also bisher war die sich die
verfeindeten alle leute die neue beim
kanal sind drei das sind davon so meine
zuschauer das war tatsächlich so wenn
präventiv gewinn nicht die beste
einsendung die wir hier hatten aber wir
machen mal weiter mit den beiden clubs
ich bin begeistert also wichtig ohne
spaß
ein bisschen gassi und übten der erst
mal über den weg traut
das getan liga und dann kommt da einfach
wieder mücken tomaten sagt um ecke
denken sie eine liste formaten warst ja
von benny kapiert worden deswegen hier
nicht ganz ganz böse an sich sollte
daher kein video einwenden können
beziehungsweise es nicht gemacht
bitte rette mich von diesem ganzen
einsendungen wird mir wieder irgendwann
in die richtung tomatensaft irgendwann
irgendwas andere siegen gegen bremen 4
[Musik]
bekomme ich jetzt einen schwarzen kappe
ich mal verschwanden
hier steht nach hält was ist das erstens
für eine sprache oder weiten 5 ok
das hat also einen jemand einer von
deinen twitter leuten hat mir einen clip
zu gelangen
von mir früher aus einem live stream
das war ducati weiterempfehlen warum
habt ihr mich abonniert das ist ich
mache doch nur scheiße da stimmt lukas
die wahrheit da frage ich mich wer wird
wirklich sehr auf die partie da wenn
mich leute fragen oder deine video liegt
immer nur so weit ich nicht kannte ich
die nicht beantworten ich wünsche nicht
schauen die vergangen wendigen leistung
erinnern etwas ein video weirich werden
würde hätte nie so hoch geladen oder
zumindest ohne kaffee hochgeladen
bestand mittlerweile an herr barbie
wiederholt in frage noch mal warum habt
ihr mich abonniert bekommt sogar ein
video zu gewinnen in denen einen pub ein
anderes pferd irgendwie so indirekt und
andere fährt weil ihnen hier um mich auf
das erfährt gerade bei meisten opfer
spürte oder auch es gehen wie mit
mitteilen sollte auf jeden fall hörte
sich das für mich im ersten moment
wirklich nicht die wirkliche derbe
witzig wenn du jetzt reinfeldt wenn ich
mir mit gebäude hätte
das war
du bist am rand über den zugefrorenen
see gelaufen
wow ich musste mich dass unter den
einwendungen wirklich leute stecken
diejenigen er neben dem talent habe ich
glaube wenn du wirklich weiterhilft und
so können aus diesem segment werden also
von der stimme her erst nein ich weiß
nicht wie alt bist aber du kannst auf
jeden fall fest verbringen als ich
meinen kollegen ist er auch wie schwer
aber wenn ich das immer mache hier so
eine folge von wegen auf videos
reagierte auch mit basilikum einem tag
da kommt ihr ding im vergleich etwas
sagt oder so vergessen dass der vogel
einfach schlichtweg gar nicht ich wollte
mir genommen
er sagt nicht immer wieder werde meine
zu hause läuft aber da dreht bieten
mehrere zehn jahren treibt ihn hier in
die täterbeschreibung geschrieben und
danach als pilot und eine gegen den mann
am tag meine damen und herren wurde die
content hier auf youtube und twitter
verbreitet einfach mal dieses video hier
vor mir und zeigt den leuten was wir
viele bescheuerte community
kurek danke danke danke wirklich für
diese motivierende einwendung als ich
eigentlich dachte ich mir gerade gewinn
habe ich verspüre gerade millionen die
in meinem körper und zeig mir deine
community hammer hey was man leichter
da und schlicht bei mir
schleim mit augen in der schweiz stand
ich dort mal nachmachen möglich bei
music kelly oder es wird wohl ein video
aufzunehmen mit der mit der melodie vor
[Musik]
ich mache das auch mal in deutschland
kunden bis den kontext gelabert zu
diesen clip und warum ihre mine wird hat
alle unter euch wie das letzte video
holt auch auf twitter videos reagiert
habe nicht gesehen habe ich verlinke das
mal hier irgendwo an der seite kommt
jetzt eine pause gefahren hätte das
video könnt ihr euch jetzt machen copen
danach nie wieder reiter schon ist der
rapide auf jeden fall wurde mir dort ein
irgendein gesendet wo eine person in
einem stadtteil in einem umkreis von
bitterfeld also der stadt wo ich mich
auch gerade befindet hat diese person
eine weile an einer bushaltestelle und
ich habe euch den westen video
aufgefordert dorthin zu gehen dass viele
leute doch in der nähe wohnen gleich
beim ersten mal davon video einwänden
wir nicht wackeln und das wurde mittels
dieses video wird wohl getan
du bist du bist mein mann deswegen weil
meine frau in der kunst auf jeden fall
das ist ungelogen einsatzzeit 4
communitys sofort ihr fit for life das
ist das echte klug dafür hab ich habe
immer überlegt mit patenten und so also
helfen lassen wir das ist die community
ihr schreibt alle mal heftig lucchini
kommentare wenn jetzt leute ich machte
mich extra dass ich immer viele klubs
nehmen aber immer von einem stoff gewagt
wird aber entweder halt einfach so viel
videomaterial 1 gesendet wo leute sind
einfach rufen oder wegen der scheiße ab
ich meine das ist cool aber ihr habt ein
bisschen kleinen dach
ja
man sieht gar nicht dafür danach jahre
google teil
doch sind der verein wendungen mir wird
eingewendet wie man in schubladen füllen
will und trimmt einfachem ich bitte
meine probleme warum stehen die meere
waren einige hatten keine wahl werde ein
video
da hatte ein mädel wirklichen talente
[Musik]
allem andere hier wieder kaputt machen
ganz netter mensch tool um einen
gravierenden auf alle klar mein herz und
ich denke da an
im video wo sich jemand leo auf die hose
sprühen hey leute ich hab vorher darüber
geredet mit allen kindern was ist das
denn
oder nennt den day kommen dort zum
letzten video von heute
also ich weiß mit ich habe schon video
hochgeladen wo ich dann ein bisschen
ausprobiert habe ich weiß nicht ob ich
das noch mal machen uns aber anscheinend
spielen doch wer viele leute von euch
mit feuer um das was sie heute von mir
meine damen und herren manager hat und
ihr mehr von deutschen video haben
wollen wo ich auf eure videos reagiere
vertreter nachbarn fashion like da
schreibt mal alle luke ruhe in die
kommentare wenn ihr also das ist jetzt
der neue name für uns ein communication
hoffe dass für viele die filmcrew oder
alpaka oder ähnliche parallele crew
zusammen letzten wir sogar an crew ich
glaube das weiß jeder
mittlerweile wissen hier findet ihr
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf wie könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren dann verpasse
keine videospiele sind kostenlos
eingeblendet und hier unten kommt ihr zu
irgendeinem anderen video